new york city police believe that ivana
trump died yesterday from an accidental
fall that's according to the associated
press former president trump called his
first wife a wonderful beautiful and
amazing woman who led a great and
inspirational life
jan crawford remembers a woman who stood
at trump's side when he first became
famous
i'm having good times always have a
great time at the plaza
in the 1980s glitzy glamorous new york
elite ivana trump was an icon as the
first wife of former president donald
trump she helped build his real estate
empire including the development of
trump tower in manhattan and the plaza
hotel
all while raising their three children
donald jr ivanka and eric that day guys
eric trump wrote on instagram that she
was an incredible woman a force in
business and caring mother and friend
she was found unresponsive at the bottom
of the stairs in her new york city upper
east side apartment thursday officials
say there were no signs of a crime and
her death will be investigated by the
medical examiner's office
a modeling trip brought the czech born
skier to new york where she met trump
they married in 1977 and a decade and a
half later it ended with a very public
divorce she even made a cameo in the
movie first wives club and remember
what don't get mad get everything
on cbs sunday morning in 2017 the author
and fashion mogul said she still spoke
regularly with her once estranged
ex-husband and then president
is he still a big part of your life
yeah he is
he's
in what way
well we
we speak to each other how often yeah
maybe once a week he asks for your
advice and he he's still asking me for
advice yes ivana trump is survived by
her three children and 10 grandchildren
for cbs mornings i'm jan crawford in
washington